[Music]
the muppets has been a beloved
institution for decades
but how much do you really know about
those fuzzy puppets
it's time to play the music and light
the lights for an in-depth look at jim
henson's beloved creations
jim henson and his muppets started
appearing on tv in the very early years
of the medium itself
in 1955 henson was hired by a washington
dc tv station to make
salmon friends a five-minute series that
aired locally just before the tonight
show
it ran for six years and centered on a
simple humanoid puppet named sam
along with other characters including a
vaguely lizard-like character
named kermit who was not yet a frog
henson who started working on the series
when he was just 18 years
old performed almost all the characters
although he was assisted by jerry jewell
and jay neville
jewell would go on to be a major
puppeteer for the muppets for decades
neville and henson married in 1959
staying together until his passing in
1990.
salmon friends led to many offers to
make commercials which funded the
henson's increasingly sophisticated
puppeteering operations
in 1963 the first major muppet
the word is a portmanteau of marionette
and puppet
got the hensons their first national
attention
ralph the dog operated and voiced by jim
henson
he was the breakout star of the jimmy
dean show a prime time variety series
hosted by the country music singer and
sausage pitch man
from then on henson's muppets were a
fixture of tv variety and talk shows
contrary to popular belief those big
whites of a muppet's eyes are not halved
table tennis balls
back in the 70s they were made out of
the cut up parts of a spherical
nesting doll-like toy called wacky
stacks
henson and his cohorts discovered that
they were the ideal muppet eye base
so much so that when the company that
made wacky stacks pulled the toy off the
market for lack of sales
henson reportedly bought out their
entire unsold stock
another unusual physical feature of
muppets is that they are
almost all left-handed that's because
most puppeteers are right-handed
and they use that dominant right hand to
control the expressive muppet areas of
the head and the mouth
the left hand is thus utilized to
control the less used and less important
muppet arms one notable exception
veteran muppeteer louise gold
she's left-handed so all of her muppets
have been designed to have a head and
mouth controlled by her left hand
and arms controlled by her right in 1969
henson wrote a proposal for a weekly
muppet series
sensibly titled the muppet show it took
five years before abc agreed to tape a
pilot and air it as a special called
the muppets valentine show critics loved
it
but abc didn't pick it up undaunted
henson pitched another version of the
show the following year
introducing new characters like sam the
eagle dr
teeth and the electric mayhem and the
swedish chef
riley retitled the muppet show sex and
violence
the special was a hit in 1975 but
not a big enough hit for abc to order
more episodes
following yet another pitch by henson
cbs
almost ordered the muppet show later
that year but again the network
ultimately passed
it wasn't until 1976 that the muppet
show finally made it to television
british television lord lou grade head
of the atv
network agreed to take on the muppet
show syndicating it to local stations
across the u.s
for five seasons a year before the
muppet show debuted in syndication
henson finally had some luck getting the
muppets on network tv
through a brand new offbeat variety show
called
nbc saturday night now known as saturday
night live
for snl henson's team created brand new
monstrous creatures for a weekly segment
called
the land of gorch but almost nobody
involved with the land of porch enjoyed
it
actors resented losing precious air time
to puppets
while ryder skilled rules prevented
henson's team from scripting the segment
meaning that it lacked that special
muppet magic
after just one season the land of gorch
was mercifully gone
are you talking about making love to me
you guys are just puppets right
i mean you don't even exist below the
waist
the beloved miss piggy has only been
around since 1974
just two years before the debut of the
muppet show
she was the creation of a muppet maker
named bonnie erickson
who also built muppet show hecklers
statler and waldorf
as well as zoot the blue saxophone
player in the electric mayhem
her inspiration for miss piggy popular
1940s and 50s jazz singer
peggy lee probably best known for the
sultry song
fever who was often billed as miss peggy
lee eriksen told smithsonian
my mother used to live in north dakota
where peggy lee sang on the local radio
station before she became a famous jazz
singer
peggy lee was a very independent woman
and piggy
certainly is the same long-time miss
piggy operator and voice performer frank
oz
came up with a backstory for the
character in a 1979 interview with the
new york times
oz revealed she grew up in a small town
in iowa
her father died when she was young and
her mother wasn't that nice to her
she had to enter beauty contests to
survive as many single women do
she has a lot of vulnerability which she
has to hide because of her need to be a
superstar
jim henson was a man of many talents not
only did he create many different
muppets
particularly kermit the frog and ernie
from sesame street but he operated them
and provided their voices too
including their singing voices in fact
two of the most famous
muppet performed songs both sung by
henson even hit the pop chart in the
1970s
in september 1970 rubber ducky credited
to ernie
jim henson peaked at number 16 on the
billboard hot 100
and in november 1979 the powerful
rainbow connection which opened the
muppet movie hit number
that song has since become a modern
classic covered by artists as disparate
as sarah mclaughlin
willie nelson kenny loggins and weezer
yet it somehow lost the oscar for best
original song
to it goes like it goes a tune from the
sally field drama
norma ray apart from the muppet show and
sesame street
the most successful muppet-oriented tv
show is muppet babies
the puppet-free saturday morning cartoon
that ran on cbs from 1984
to 1991. jim henson had long wanted to
explore a show or movie based on the
muppets as babies or children
but it took a sequence in the muppets
take manhattan for it to happen
toy companies lined up for the rights to
sell muppet baby merchandise
it was clear the demand was there and in
the fall of 1984
the cartoon debuted it was a smash hit
and throughout its run it was often the
highest rated saturday morning cartoon
on tv
muppet babies had its detractors however
primarily frank oz who felt it
diminished the characters
and a 1985 spin-off cartoon called
little muppet monsters
disappeared after just three episodes
showing there's a limit to how much
cuteness one fan base can handle
prior to the release of the 1996 film
muppet treasure island
the muppets were served with a lawsuit
by hormel
the company that makes spam why well it
had nothing to do with miss piggy
but rather with the film's new warthog
character who was named
spa am hormel claimed the character
could damage sales of their infamous
canned meat product
judges ultimately sided with henson
arguing that spam had been a punchline
for a long time with no harm done
with countless comedians and writers
questioning the content of the product
spam spam spam spam spam spam fake beans
spam spam
and spam the ruling read in part
one might think hormel would welcome the
association with a genuine source of
pork
that wasn't the only muppet-based
lawsuit though and the next one
was much messier as it included muppet
on muppet violence
in 2018 jim henson's son brian henson
came out with a film called the happy
time murders
a r-rated comedy about muppet crime that
co-starred melissa mccarthy
the film's marketing included the
tagline no sesame
all street that in turn drew the ire of
the sesame workshop
the non-profit muppet division that
creates sesame street
they sued claiming that the tagline
deliberately confuses consumers into
mistakenly believing that sesame is
associated with
has allowed or has even endorsed or
produced the movie
and tarnishes sesame's brand sesame
workshop lost the case when a judge
ruled that the company couldn't prove
that its reputation had been damaged by
the happy time murders
a movie which ultimately bombed at the
box office
the muppets returned to the big screen
for the first time in more than a decade
with 2011's the muppets the script was
co-written by its
human star muppet superfan jason siegel
best known for freaks and geeks and how
i met your mother
siegel took a suggestion from freaks and
geek's producer judd apatow
to get more acting work by writing his
own material so he wrote the screenplay
for the 2008 film
forgetting sarah marshall which included
a puppet musical version of dracula
to make the puppets siegel and his
collaborators sought out the jim henson
company
at an early meeting everyone in
attendance got a puppet to goof around
with
but according to forgetting sarah
marshall director nicholas staller
jason was playing with the puppet the
whole time during this business meeting
it was looking at people looking at him
as he was talking
siegel's enthusiasm so impressed henson
executives that they got him a meeting
with the muppet's corporate parent
disney where he straight up pitched a
brand new muppet movie
the rest was box office history steve
wittmeyer joined the muppets in the 70s
operating puppets in the muppet movie
and on the muppet show
and finding his signature character
during the 80s in rizzo the wrath
wittmeyer took over kermit the frog
after the death of jim henson in 1990
and continued with the character until
he was suddenly fired in 2016.
according to a statement from muppet
studio whitmire's firing wasn't that
sudden though
instead being the result of what they
called quote steve's repeated
unacceptable business conduct over a
period of many years
brian henson elaborated saying that
among other things
whitmire would quote send emails and
letters attacking everyone
attacking the writing and attacking the
director whitmer told the hollywood
reporter that he simply felt he knew
kermit's character better than just
about anybody
and that he argued passionately against
things he felt were out of character
like a plot point on the short-lived
2015 series the muppets
in which kermit lied to his nephew robin
it was an uh totally an idea of trying
to do what was best for the muppets
while there have been dozens of
muppet-based shows and films
there are nearly as many proposed
projects that never saw the light of day
going as far back as the 1960s when they
pitched a show called
the adventures of ralph in outer space
in which ralph visits other planets via
his homemade spaceship
other shows that failed to launch
included muppet high
which would have centered on the muppets
as high school students in the 1950s
america's next muppet a parody of the
reality show
america's next top model where kermit
and piggy would judge aspirants who
wanted to become the next star
muppet and muppets live another day
which was going to be a 1980s set
six-part scripted series that took place
after the events of the 1984 movie
the muppets take manhattan disney
announced muppets live another day at
their d23 convention in 2019
to much fanfare the plot kermit gets the
muppets together to locate a vanished
ralph
broadway star frozen voice actor josh
gad
signed up to write the show with once
upon a time heads adam horowitz and
edward kitsis
why are you wearing muppet pants just a
couple of weeks later though
gad announced that after more than a
year of work on muppets live another day
the series had exploded like one of
crazy harry's devices
he tweeted sadly eddie kitsis adam
horowitz and i have decided to step away
from muppets live another day
sometimes creative differences are just
that instead disney pivoted to muppets
now
which debuted on the disney plus
streaming service in 2020.
just what comes next for the muppets is
anyone's guess
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite characters are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one